there's a story from a few days ago that
I've been meaning to cover haven't had
the time to you but I do want to address
it there's a Christian couple from
Canberra Australia who says that they're
going to divorce if Australian law
changes to allow same-sex marriage and
I'm talking about Nick and Sarah Jensen
they've been married for more than ten
years they are saying that as a merit as
a matter of conscience they're not going
to recognize the government's regulation
of marriage if that definition begins to
include same-sex couples they've called
marriage the fundamental and
foundational building block of
Australian society and culture
everywhere and they're willing to end
their own marriage if two men or two
women can get married I'm wondering Pat
how strong is the bond of marriage to
begin with if two dudes getting married
makes it so you need to end your own
marriage that's the thing I mean when
gay marriage was being debated in the
United States one of the weakest
arguments we heard from the other side
was that it would somehow undermine
straight marriages yeah and I think
these people are just kind of out to
bolster that argument more than anything
else they're going to prove the sanctity
of Christian marriage by breaking the
sanctity of Christian marriage that's
really gonna teach them who them is I
have absolutely no idea and more
interesting is that in exposing the
absurdity of all this is that in
Australia if you want to divorce on
paper but plan to continue living
together because let's be completely
upfront here this is a couple who would
maybe divorce on paper but they're still
going to live together and continue
their lives as normal in Australia you
need to in order to get a divorce
granted by a court legally you need to
convince the court or satisfy the court
that you and your spouse have lived
separately and apart for at least 12
months and that there's no reasonable
likelihood of resuming married life if
you say we want to divorce oh really
well how long have you been living apart
well oh no we still live together they
probably wouldn't even be able to get
the divorce that would just be a protest
sham to begin with yeah this is entirely
speculation but what if they want to get
a divorce anyway but don't consider it
the right Christian thing to do yeah and
this is their excuse for doing it well I
was thinking that it's actually a sin
number one get divorced in Christianity
and it's a sin number two to live
together without being married so in
order to protest what they see is I
guess the sin of same-sex marriage they
seem willing to commit two different
sins of course if you called them on it
they'd probably say oh no no no we're
divorced on paper but we're still
married in the eyes of the Lord which is
also hilarious because when it comes to
gay marriage they wouldn't accept the
distinction between religious marriage
and civil marriage you could say to them
when they say I'm against this the state
recognizing same-sex marriage you could
say to the bigots
well hold on if you believe that under
God only same-sex marriage is valid then
allow the state to do whatever it wants
let the state hand out same-sex marriage
licenses because legal marriage is not
the same as godly marriage of course
they would say no no that's not okay yet
now if you tell them that they're
sinning by getting divorced
they might say it's different because
our civil marriage has nothing to do
with how God sees us it's two totally
different things
what is this really expose Pat I think
it exposes that the double standards
from the bigoted Christian right are
falling very quickly apart thanks for
watching this video before you watch the
next one remember we're raising money to
expand the David Pakman show big league
as well as expand progressive activism
go to david pakman.com slash donate
donations of any size are much
appreciated